las cárceles de Colombia no están
exentas de la actualidad en la picota la
mayor del país los reclusos participaron
en la instalación de la mesa nacional
por la paz total concepto acuñado por el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro y su
vicepresidenta Francia Márquez detrás
del evento instituciones pero también
organizaciones sociales como Esperanza
Bustamante de la corporación corazón
humano que Acompaña a mujeres en prisión
y todos ellos pueden ser interlocutores
para las personas que están afuera de
que se unan al proceso del paz en el
evento participan desde excombatientes
de la guerrilla de izquierda de las FARC
hasta antiguas autodefensas también
conocidas como paramilitares y
vinculadas a la ultraderecha guardan los
secretos de 70 años de conflicto la mesa
pretende que se aporte a la verdad y
poder reparar a las víctimas con
testimonios como el de Martín Llanos
antiguo comandante de autodefensas
campesinas del casanare y de su padre
Héctor buitrago uno de los primeros
fundadores de las autodefensas del país
los gobiernos que han manejado este país
No han permitido la inclusión de todos
sus ciudadanos Entonces nos hemos
enfrascado en una confrontación de
derecha y de izquierda
pero que al final no hemos podido lograr
nada
los presos que participan confían en que
se cumpla una máxima las cárceles son el
reflejo de la sociedad y en Colombia
personas que un día se mataron por unos
ideales llevan años conviviendo
pacíficamente en celdas como Jacinto
Alberto Soto toro alias Lucas el que
fuera el jefe financiero de los hermanos
castaño uno de los clanes más temidos de
la historia de Colombia y Alexander
botía político detenido por supuestos
vínculos con las disidencias de las Farc
en un espacio de nueve metros cuatro
personas y no nos agarramos a pelear por
nada ha generado nosotros la confianza
de poderle manifestar al mundo exterior
a las sociedades que sí puede haber paz
que pueda haber convivencias y exista la
diferencia es el primer paso que dará
lugar a meses de negociaciones entre los
distintos frentes del conflicto para
lograr al fin una nueva historia para
Colombia
[Aplausos]